Venezuelan president says four more
people have been arrested after a failed
incursion attempt a former u.s. veteran
says he organized the raid which
Venezuela claims was ultimately
orchestrated by Washington in New
Orleans and I have to report that four
new terrorists have just been captured
I've already ordered the Foreign
Minister to send a set of reports with
the corresponding videos with the
corresponding contracts on these
aggressions conducted by the United
States government and Donald Trump
against Venezuela the u.s. denies any
involvement two of its citizens were
among the first arrests though they were
detained on Monday and identified as
former Special Forces soldiers during
President Maduro as virtual news
conference the questioning of one of the
men was televised with more on all this
Kalib mopin u.s. Venezuela tensions are
high once again the Latin American
socialist country says it has held off
an armed incursion
now they've captured mercenary fighters
two of which are US citizens and one of
the mercenary fighters says the plan was
to detain Maduro and hand him over to
the United States the only instructions
that I received from Jordan was to
ensure that we
[Music]
on Wednesday we heard a full denial from
Mike Pompeo
he says the United States was not in on
the plot however he's now making threats
unless the two detained US citizens are
released as no US government direct
involvement in this operation
we'd have been involved it would have
gone differently the Maduro regime
decides to hold them we'll use every
tool that we have available to try and
get them back president Maduro maintains
he knows exactly who is responsible for
the raid we were able to uncover this
terrorist incursion of which we have
been victims we know that the United
States government assigned the Drug
Enforcement Agency to plan this action
and assign the private company silver
core for the operational planning the
government of the United States of
America is fully and completely involved
in the Israeli defeated by the solid
civic military police union of Venezuela
silver Corp is an American corporation
headed by Jordan Godhra there's no video
of him confirming the botched operation
silver Corp has also threatened to kill
an rtii Spanish correspondent after she
tweeted about an alleged invasion into
Venezuela and eloquent as a journalist I
have followed the online account of this
alleged war veteran and who said to have
been decorated three times back home for
his participation in the Iraq war after
a long period of absence yesterday took
to the online account of silver court
USA claiming that his incursion would
involve over 60 people here in Venezuela
I made a report and this person replied
that mercenaries may be paid to kill
people but he would kill me for free
fortunately I have received many
messages of support from both the
Venezuelan government and also from
abroad and so now we move forward with
our work because the most important
thing is to continue in denouncing
what's taking
in our country the Russian embassy
responded to this public threat of
violence we noticed an explicit threat
to the RT journalist US authorities and
human rights activists who keen on
seeking out the violators of freedom of
speech outside the United States keep
silence apparently they continued to
celebrate World Press Freedom Day with
the world shut down by the ongoing
global pandemic many would argue now is
the time for cooperation between
countries however it's pretty clear that
US leaders have decided that their
efforts to destabilize Venezuela and
topple its government must not be put on
hold it is clear is that the Venezuelan
opposition Juan Y doe the so-called
interim president has his name on his
contract with the coup leader silver
corn mercenary Jordan Boudreau and at
the very least the Venezuelan opposition
has turned to private means to carry out
a military coup which is technically an
act of war US State Department is very
embarrassed by this they don't want
anything to do with it whether or not
they did have fingerprints on the
operation and now it appears that Jordan
Goudreau the ringleader who was
contracted by one wydo will be
prosecuted by the US government for arms
trafficking so they're clearly trying to
establish legal distance with one
grideau
so it just look makes Trump and his team
look like a bunch of buffoons on the
world stage
you